[Music]
in the season 7 finale show finally
confirmed that Jon Snow is a legitimate
son of Prince Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark however John still knows
nothing and therefore many fans are
wondering how will JAL learn the truth
regarding his show lineage and how will
he be able to confirm it two other high
lords and ladies of Westeros sure bran
could share what he saw in his vision or
Howland Reed could tell him the truth
but the only way for the revelation to
have its full effect is for Jon to
discover it on his own which brings us
to the crypts of Winterfell
for the past few years fans have been
speculating that Jon find out his show
parentage in the crypts of interval as
many believe that Ned hit a hint for
Jon's summer in the crypts in any case
the crypts have been included in both
the books and the show which along with
all scenes that took place over there in
the show and we told Josh dreams and
visions about it in the books has led
many people to believe that there's
something about him of high significance
to the upcoming plot however the
question remains did Ned hide a hint for
Jon and will the white-walled fight out
that same hidden object that would reel
to him that he's not as bastard but
rather son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen before i focus on a possible
object that might be hidden somewhere in
the crypts let's see what facts would
have even led Ned to hide it below
Winterfell the cribs are located below
Winterfell and that contained the tombs
of the members of House Stark are
massive and they're larger than the
entire Castle complex about ground so it
seems possible that naturally did hide
it somewhere inside crypts isn't only it
would be hard to find it but it's also
the last place someone would look for
there are only a very few people that
are visiting the crypts which this scene
from the fourth episode of the fifth
season is confirming as we can see while
visiting the stark family crypts beside
relating the Kendall's sense also picks
up the Feder of the floor which is the
same fetter that Robert Baratheon placed
on the hand of a statue of Leanna in the
very first episode of the show let me
also introduce Yvette a free folk legend
which states that Bale the bard who was
the King beyond the wall disappeared
from Winterfell with the daughter of
Lord Brandon Stark the daughter
eventually reappeared with an infant a
future Lord Stark with the legend
claiming that they had hid within the
crypts but all this being said it's easy
to say why would net have hidden
something of a huge importance and
crypts there's most certainly high
possibility that Ned took something from
the Tower of joy something related to
the truth about John's parentage and hid
it in the crypts before I continue let
me just give you an answer on a very
common question regarding this topic
which is if naturally did hide
for John veterus Rhaegar's widely
popular harp or Targaryen sword or
something entirely else how is it
possible that no one accidentally came
up to it before well an obvious answer
on that question would be he hid it very
well many fans are still wondering how
will John presumably find it out if it
successful be hidden for all those years
a Song of Ice and Fire which is a series
of epic fantasy novels written by George
Armand on which Game of Thrones his base
gave us a few hints regarding this
question in the book Jack has recurring
nightmares about wandering around the
crypts in the very first novel in Song
of Ice and Fire while at Castle black
john tells Sam that he sometimes dreams
of the crypts john says that he walks
deeper into the crypts but is afraid of
what he will find within them and
awakens every time when the crypts
become too dark John says the same that
he knows he has to go down there but he
doesn't want to as he is afraid of what
might be waiting for him I think it's
easy to assume that the crypts may be
hiding plenty of secrets within them
including a secret object--the at will
Joshua parentage - Jack himself it will
most certainly be interesting to see if
John's dreams will lead him to go inside
the crypts and eventually find out the
turgi related object that would firstly
have him confused but one's brain or
same or even Howland revealed to him the
truth it would be an official
confirmation now let's see which object
Ned might have hidden below Winterfell
in the crypts many fans are assuming the
Jamelia find out dark sister or black
fire whichever Luna still soars
belonging to House Targaryen Aegon the
conquerer wielded black fire in the
battle during the war of conquest while
later it was also valid by many of the
more marshal Targaryen Kings which would
sue John perfectly however black fire
was later given by Aegon the unworthy to
his bastard son daemon which eventually
removed the sword from House Targaryen
possession as Damon founded his own
lineage house Blackfyre taking the name
of the sword the sword black fire
remained in the hands of each successor
generation house Blackfyre until the
line was wiped out the swords current
owner and location is unknown but it
most certainly is not hidden in the
crypts of interval as its last known
location is not even investor OHS but
rather in the Free Cities located in
Essos dark sister on the other hand
belonged to visi a Targaryen the sister
wife of Aegon the conquerer
the sword was allegedly lost during the
Blackfyre rebellion it most certainly is
nearer hidden summer in the crypts even
though we might have already seen it in
the show the last known builder of dark
sister was Prince former trainer Brandon
rivers who used it in his famous duel
with his half-brother the swords fate
after bloodraven was stripped of
his titles and exile to the wall remains
unknown however in the fifth episode of
the sixth season we might have seen this
famous sword when Mira rush to the
entrance of the cave and saw the vast
army of the Dead she went into the cave
and picked up a sword that might be a
dark sister
Mira did not even have a sword with her
while entering the cave of the
three-eyed Raven meaning it's not hers
but rather Bloods Raven sword giving it
a high possibility that the sordid Mira
picked up Shirley's dark sister this
shot from the sixth episode of the sixth
season provided us a better look on it
but we still didn't get to see the whole
sword to be able to confirm that this
sword is a famous ancestral sword of
House Targaryen additionally we need a
sword at mere picked up is dark sister I
doubt Jamil will did once he finds out
his true parentage since our sister has
been forged for a woman warrior at the
slender blade is designed for a woman's
hand
anyway Gemma's journal will not find out
the lost her Garin family sword in the
crypts of Winterfell and it will not be
an object that will reveal or confirm to
Jon his true parentage
so the question still remains what
didn't Stark hide in the crypts taking
to account that an object that were
revealed to John Snow his sure parentage
should be well known to the high lords
and ladies of the realm as well as to
John himself there's a high possibility
that Ned Stark he draggers widely
popular harp and it will eventually
confirm to Jon his qu lineage Rhaegar
sharp might be one of if not the only
object that Rhaegar might have left in
the Tower of joy with his beloved Lyanna
stark why would have he left it well not
only that Lee and I enjoyed listening
Rhaegar playing harp but he also most
likely did not carry his harp while
marching in the war there's also one
fact that is going favor to this theory
which is there has not been a mention of
Rhaegar sharp during or after Robert's
rebellion it might be implying that
Reger beside leaving his best friend and
the greatest fighter the Seven Kingdoms
has ever seen to protect Liana inter
unborn son Rhaegar most likely also at
his Harpootlian in the Tower of joy as a
symbol for Lyanna of his love towards
her and promised to return however upon
Rhaegar's death during the battle the
Trident and Napoleon is debt in the
hands of Ned at the Tower of joy it
seems possible the Ned took Rhaegar
scarp along with cleanest corpse and he
did some very nearly and a statue in the
crypts of interval not only that once
Jon Snow finds out the truth from any
character whether it will be from Sam
brain or Howland Reed
not only that Rhaegar sharp in the
crypts would be an official confirmation
for John himself but it will also be
approved for all high lords and ladies
that John is not a Ned's bastard but
rather son of Liana and Rhaegar
Targaryen
it would be an ultimate proof since
every single character knows
the unique characteristics of ragas harp
about its silver strings I'm sure most
of you heard the multiple theories which
fans claim that regards famous carved is
supposedly going to reveal john the
truth is hidden inside lee in a stoom
well it does make sense since leon and
Rhaegar loved each other at the same
time it doesn't why doesn't well for
John to either find out or confirm the
truth this way he or anyone else would
have to openly in a stoom
and I highly doubt that it's going to
happen there are also some who claim
that harp might not necessarily be
inside the tomb but rather nearly in a
statue
however it's most likely in that case as
well since Ned must have known that his
friend Robert and several family members
would be frequent visitors sadly in a
stone if naturally did hydrators sharp
under Winterfell with intention for John
to find it someday I'll place my bet on
the tum no one knew existed as a pastor
john doesn't get a tomb on his own in
the crypts so Ned would have had to have
one made for John in secret we know that
Ned had his empty tomb already prepared
before his death in fact we are told
that there are numerous empty unsealed
tombs prepared for not only Ned but also
for his children in the book Jonathan
dreams of the crypts of Winterfell in
which he sees the statues of the kings
of winter watching him as he passes them
John sees the stone star king-size
following him as they tell him he
doesn't belong there which will imply
that John is in fact already given a
place in addition it has similar dreams
of the crypts as John which could be a
hint that he has angered the old kings
of winter by giving John a place even
though he isn't a stark but rather a
Targaryen I believe that tomb was
prepared for John in the Winterfell
crypts hidden away in the lower levels
in it will be rehgar upon the crown
winter roses regulate only in a slap at
the tourney at Harrenhal when he crowned
her queen of love and beauty as he is
carrying out his dream he will get to
the point where he would usually wake up
instead he will keep going and he will
discover a to man for him in case you're
wondering didn't that have to keep
John's parentage a secret that he
promised to his sister or did not have
the stonemason killed after this one
made a tombstone for John aka Aegon
Targaryen the answer is no in fact the
answer lies in the conversation between
Tywin and Tara in season 2 episode 7 in
that scene not knowing who are actually
is blaming she's daughter of a
stonemason from the north tile surprise
when she told him that her alleged
stonemason father taught her how to read
diving said he was a well-read
stonemason can't say I've ever met a
literate stonemason
anyways according to reliable sources
it's been confirmed that at least first
two episodes of season 8 we'll see the
return of the
reportedly one of those scenes includes
two main characters discussing Nets
death
this sounds similar to scene between
Sansa and Arya only this case one of two
characters will most likely be John
himself and if I had to guess I'd say
it's John and Danny recently there was
filmed another scene in Shane's castle
in ancient ruins structure that's been
used throughout the show as a crypts of
interval and it also included two main
characters again John is most likely one
of those two however this time the two
are interrupted with a horn being blown
in conclusion the crypts have been
included in both the books and the show
which along with all scenes that took
place or they're in the show and we told
John dreams and visions about it in the
books give us a reason to believe it
will play a major role in the huge
revelation for John it will most
certainly be interesting to see how and
what shadowfied out in the crypts of
interval Reger's unique harp and Lina's
crown of blue roses that's in my opinion
hidden in Aegon Targaryen storming the
crypts of Winterfell will be an official
confirmation for John as Velas for all
lords and ladies in Westeros that John
truly is a Targaryen and as always let
me know your opinion about all of this
in the comment section down below I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you the next
piece
[Music]
[Music]